[Música]
y llegó el momento de repasar la prensa
internacional con rosa pérez masdéu rosa
feliz miércoles bienvenida muy buen día
vamos a comenzar hoy con moscú en rusia
con el moscú times dice rusia promete
represalias por el bloqueo youtube los
canales alemanes de rusia today nosotros
ya avanzamos esta información en el
noticiero de las seis de la mañana rosa
que hay sobre esto pues buenos días raúl
exactamente empezamos con esta noticia
que ya ha sido calificada de guerra
mediática por la propia editora en jefe
de rusia today margarita simonián que
básicamente contextualicemos recordemos
lo que nos ha explicado nuestro
corresponsal
xavier colás y es que youtube ha
bloqueado en alemania las cadenas
alemanas de rusia today que es un medio
público ruso y alega que lo ha hecho por
una supuesta desinformación por parte de
rusia today en informaciones
relacionadas con el coronavirus ahora
bien lo que está pasando es que ya la
propia dirección de raya today así como
las autoridades rusas están viendo de
qué forma a lo que consideran esto un
ataque y una guerra mediática entre
rusia y alemania- y está sobre la mesa
el bloqueo de youtube en toda rusia lo
que supondría una pérdida de millones de
usuarios y/o por otro lado el bloqueo de
medios al públicos alemanes también en
rusia y recordemos raúl que ya youtube
de hecho
google porque recordemos que youtube
pertenece a google pues ya estuvo en el
punto de mira de lo que es la crítica a
la libertad de expresión en las
recientes elecciones legislativas de
rusia pero esta vez fue por el bando
opuesto porque tanto google como apple
bloquearon a la aplicación creada por la
oposición vinculada a naval ni que se
llamaba voto inteligente y que te
indicaba pues qué candidatos podías
votar con el objetivo de restar mayoría
al oficialismo de putin en el parlamento
ruso y lo peor de todo con estos
conflictos es como siempre los usuarios
las personas nosotros somos los que nos
vemos más afectados siempre vamos ahora
con el 'new york times' facebook no es a
prueba de escándalos qué quiere decir
con esto rosa
mira hemos querido fijarnos en este
artículo que está redactado por xirau
bites que es una de las principales
periodistas en temas de tecnología y
plataformas digitales de este periódico
del new york times y que tiene una
newsletter diaria y se fija mucho en el
poder de las plataformas digitales bien
pues en este artículo o byte lo que
defiende es que facebook está perdiendo
poder pues porque está perdiendo al
mismo tiempo reputación y hace una
comparación muy ilustrativa y es que
dice facebook hasta ahora era como el
teflón le resbalaba cualquier escándalo
pues le resbalaba cualquier marca de
suciedad por decirlo así no pero que
poco a poco pues está teniendo cada vez
más repercusión en su poder pues en los
escándalos a que se le han ido
atribuyendo y nos da distintos datos por
un lado que desde 2017 cuando tuvo lugar
el escándalo de cambridge analítica pues
desde entonces facebook sólo ha crecido
un 8 por ciento en eeuu y canadá
recordemos que estos datos sólo hacen
referencia a fe como tal y no a otras
aplicaciones que tiene también la misma
plataforma facebook como son instagram o
whatsapp y dice pues esta pérdida de
confianza porque facebook nos dice es el
gigante digital en el que menos confían
los ciudadanos estadounidenses pues esta
falta de confianza es la que está
llevando a que facebook retire del
mercado algunas de sus propuestas como
es pues la propuesta que retiró valga la
redundancia el año pasado sobre su
potencial moneda digital y recientemente
el anuncio que hizo a principios de esta
semana sobre la retirada de instagram
kids rosa y seguimos hablando de la
empresa facebook vamos ahora con the
wall street journal los esfuerzos de
facebook para atraer a preadolescentes
iban más allá de instagram que proponen
ahora y pues yo no soy pres adolescente
estoy lejos ya que ya pasé por esa época
pero yo siento que es verdad que usamos
menos facebook cada día más no exacto
raúl mira precisamente la noticia que
comentábamos que ahora mismo nos trae a
esta nueva información y es que el wall
street journal desde un par de semanas
está desvelando una investigación propia
que se llama los papeles de facebook y
que precisamente hace eso un par de
semanas desvelaba que facebook digamos
por la parte que le pertoca de instagram
es perfectamente consciente del daño que
que causa su aplicación sobre todo en un
sector muy importante de sus usuarios
que son las chicas preadolescentes y es
que salió como informes internos de
facebook desvelaban que incluso un 40
por ciento de las chicas que usan
facebook dicen sentirse peor con su
cuerpo y su autoestima después de usar
esta aplicación pues ahora hay una nueva
revelación de este periódico que dice
que facebook está muy preocupado por
perder este sector tan importante de
nuevos potenciales usuarios como son los
preadolescentes y que entren en el
mercado de las plataformas ya dejando de
lado facebook o instagram y entrando
directamente a usar plataformas muy
populares como stick top rosa usted usa
facebook o tick tock o instagram que yo
que más usa pues me cada vez uso menos
raúl también he de decirte que pues esto
se ha comentado muchísimo y es que estas
plataformas tienen departamentos enteros
dedicados a la dopamina que es lo que
nos hace mantenernos adictos no a
consultar regularmente estas
aplicaciones pero en la medida de lo
posible de lo posible pues también me
reconozco como una víctima de esto pero
en la medida de lo posible intentó
dejarlo cada vez más de lado todos
estamos inmersos en las redes sociales
rosas muchísimas gracias por la revista
de prensa el día de hoy vamos con
nuestro primer invitado al día